grab your popcorn because the Democrats
are fighting again moderate Joe manchin
is furious with Joe Biden after the
president promised to shut down all coal
plants across America
we're now changing the nature of the the
life of a battery
folks it's also now cheaper to generate
electricity
from wind and solar than it is from coal
and oil literally cheaper we're going to
be shutting these plants down all across
America and having wind and solar it's
going to become a wind generation and
all they're doing is they're going to
save them a hell of a lot of money Joe
manchin demanding Biden apologize in a
scathing statement that says quote
President Biden's comments are not only
outrageous and divorced from reality
they ignore the severe economic pain the
American people are feeling because of
rising energy costs comments like these
are the reason the American people are
losing trust in President Biden and
instead believes he does not understand
the need to have an all-in energy policy
that would keep our nation totally
energy independent and secure
and the White House was forced to once
again clean up Biden's remarks by saying
his words had been quote twisted oh all
right so the first question that I have
Jesse is when Biden goes in after making
a tone deaf statement like that to the
detriment of Democrats running across
this country who comes out and decides
they need to clean it up I know Kareem
Jean-Pierre came out well who behind the
curtains is calling the shots and saying
this has to be redone this has to be
re-explained clean treasury energy
everybody knows he put his foot in his
mouth so it doesn't matter who they all
know Joe screwed up I don't know who to
root for in this fight because I've had
it with both of these guys Biden's been
saying he's trying to get rid of fossil
fuels for years
but at Mansion just was he born
yesterday he just realized that now all
of a sudden that's disgusting now if
Harold convinced me not to hit mansion
that hard so I might hit him less hard
but this guy gave Joe Biden a trillion
in a green slush fund and then was like
oh maybe it'll cause infration he broke
my heart let's put it that way Mansion
broke my heart Joe Biden says we're
gonna get rid of coal and do wind and
solar but that's not what Delaware did
Delaware got rid of coal and then just
uses natural gas Delaware's 92 percent
natural gas they don't have a single
offshore wind
turbine and they only have one solar
panel why doesn't somebody ask Joe Biden
hey why Joe also where are these workers
going to go work after they get fired
from these cold jobs are they going to
join forces with the laid off
Keystone Pipeline guys where are they
going to go make electric batteries
somewhere not at Ford because Ford moved
the electric battery manufacturing plant
to Mexico that's kind of a long commute
yeah and also Dana do you remember
solyndra during the Obama Administration
where we lost a half a billion dollars
when with a country that some new was
going Bank a company some new was going
bankrupt are we back to solar panels
again well solyndra was our favorite
story on the five and we did it over and
over again the Democrats should have
watched us then as well half a billion
though that's nothing yeah remember we
thought that was something yeah that
used to be a lot of money yes no it's
nothing um Joe Biden just said what he
truly believes and we remember Hillary
Clinton said the same thing in 2016 and
that was a big deal because all the
Democrats are well wait you can't say
that but it is what they mean and it is
what energizes they need that left-wing
side of the democratic party to be
energized in this election so that's why
they say it I thought it was kind of
ridiculous that the White House came out
and said we apologize but Joe Biden's
words were Twisted what was twisted yeah
I read nobody Twisted it he actually
said that so it's not being Twisted it
is what you mean you say what you mean
you mean what you say and that's what
people will think of the political
realignment that's happening is pretty
interesting with working-class voters so
you're going to see that on Tuesday also
I would add this Joe manchin is up for
reelection in 2024 and I think he will
have a very tough race on his hands
that's interesting what do you think
Carol so I like the fact one of the
things that that you should like in
politics is when a party can have an
open Feud two days before an election
you don't see this in the Republic
concerning Jesse and I was we were
talking about this all fair I hope that
if Republicans take the Senate I don't
hope they take it but if they do I hope
that their voices in the Republican
Party in the Senate who will stand up to
Republicans when they think they are
they're spending too much going
overboard being excessive number one
number two there's no question we need
more domestic energy production in the
country be it cold be it natural gas get
any fossil fuel that we're able to
produce here when we were the biggest
producer for a long period of time and
it started under President Obama he
didn't have the right posture towards it
but it happened under him three not only
should we have an all the above strategy
any Republican if you win the majority
of Housing and said I pleaded
Republicans please don't support Putin
the one thing that will drive up energy
costs more is if we expand their Horizon
and strength of an autocrat and if we
expand his ability to produce natural
gas and for that matter to produce
energy products the single greatest
inflationary upward pressure in our
economy are gas prices and energy prices
we should produce more here and we
should support zelinski to defeat Putin
because if he's in power forward if he's
in if his thing is enriched it will only
make energy more expensive which makes
food more expensive our clothing more
expensive things to make your your suits
darker those great shoes of yours uh
Greg darker the reality is in your shoes
too judge we need to ensure that we
produce more here and we don't we don't
Empower Putin in the process all right
you know what amen Greg amen with
respect to Putin he shouldn't even be in
the picture we should be energy
independent yeah whose fault is that a
Democrat exactly I blame Harold Ford
uh for everything everything that's gone
wrong in my life I Blame You what are we
talking about energy right would he the
thing that gets me mad it wasn't it
wasn't the getting rid of coal plants
it's when he says wind and solar and you
know okay if that's how you feel you
first
you are not relying on wind the white
house isn't relying on wind the white
house isn't relying on solar
he's lying and everybody I I think this
is it this is I don't know how it got
started but we politicized even energy
whereas you should be able to have this
kind of like basically objective view
that like yeah let's use this stuff
maybe it's not that great let's look at
this other stuff maybe this stuff's
coming along but in the meantime let's
do this how did it become left and right
when did this happen I didn't buy into
that I don't think you bought into it I
don't know where it I guess there has to
be you have to follow the money and find
out who makes money by pitting us
against each other when Greta when Greta
uh what's her name
says don't get rid of the nuclear power
plants because we need them that tells
you that maybe the stuff's starting to
crack I hope it is but the last thing is
like you know when I listen to Biden he
reminds me I guess what you call a bingo
spinner you know you spin it ball pops
out that's his brain and then it pops
out and he reads what's on the ball goes
gotta get rid of coal plants then he
throws the ball away and then he does it
again he's a he's basically a bingo ball
spinner Dana and that's no euphemism you
dirty
I want to Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now